horror films are supposed to scare us
it's right there in the name of the
genre after all the whole reason we line
up to watch horror movies is to
experience the safe thrill of being
terrified by fictional objects on a
screen it's all totally fake of course
but there have been times when the
scares hit a little too close to home
and some of the scariest movie scenes
have even managed to frighten the actors
and actresses bringing them to life
here are some iconic movie scenes that
scared the pants off the actors in real
life alien when that tiny alien bursts
out of John Hurt's chest an alien it
scared everyone including the cast
although the special effects themselves
were pretty shocking the real magic of
this scene is how surprised and
terrified the cast appears these
horrified faces are genuine John Hurt
was taken aside during shooting and
rigged up to a device loaded with rancid
pig organs the rest of the cast was
brought in unaware of the device about
to spray them with the organs or why the
film crew was wearing rain gear and
protective plastic sheeting the first
take strategically brought the crew
closer to the table by spurting only a
small amount of fake blood so when the
next take left them all covered in blood
their faces expressed true terrified
surprise there's a master where all five
of us are like and we're not acting the
Texas Chainsaw Massacre the 1974 horror
classic the Texas Chainsaw Massacre is
another example of a director
strategically designing scenarios to
elicit real terror from the actors and
actresses director tobe Hooper kept his
star Leatherface played by Gunnar Hansen
out of sight from the rest of the crew
so his mask would be a most horrifying
surprise
specifically when Jerry runs into him
for the first time in the kitchen his
high-pitched squeal is absolutely real
the Blair Witch Project this entire film
seems to have been planned as an
elaborate scheme to slowly push the cast
into going insane the directors of The
Blair Witch Project gave the three cast
members cameras supplies for survival
and a place to meet up from there the
three were essentially left alone in the
woods a few scenes from the movie are
from when they were actually lost trying
to figure out the next meet-up point
oftentimes the directors would secretly
follow the cast and break sticks or
throw rocks around the unknowing campers
and every once in a while if it was dark
you see this red beam and you knew it
was it was the haxon band of goons
worse yet the directors gave them less
food every day to make them ragged angry
and more on edge and as the days went on
the filmmakers came up with new ways to
torture their actors and then they were
setting up you know sound loops of
babies crying and kids laughing outside
of 10:00 at 4:00 in the morning
basically was just us running through
trees and going nuts out there after 8
days of filming it's safe to say that
the cast no longer enjoys walks in the
woods prometheus after alien you'd think
actors would all be on red alert
any time Ridley Scott makes a monster
flick but the actors on prometheus
evidently thought the directors
trickster days were over
allowing Scott to get in one more scare
in one of Prometheus his most infamous
scenes a biologist tries petting the
world's scariest space Cobra it doesn't
end well a little later his friends
stumble across his corpse and when they
turned his body over the monster shoots
up out of his mouth as you probably
guessed by this point those screams are
genuine pulling pretty much the exact
same stunt he used more than 30 years
ago Scott replaced actor Rafe spall with
a dummy loaded the alien puppet in its
mouth and connected the alien creature
to a wire he then told everyone on set
to keep quiet and make sure the actors
didn't see the storyboards for the day
when actress Kate Dickey rolled the
corpse over a crew member yanked the
monster out of the dummy's mouth causing
Dickie to Yelp and alarm even tough guy
idris elba who was standing nearby let
out a squeal of surprise the monster
squad the monster squad is a unique 80s
movie that pits a group of kids against
some of the most famous monsters in
cinematic history of course the scariest
of the bunch is Count Dracula himself
played by Duncan regard this
Transylvanian vampire wants to get his
undead hands on an amulet that will help
him conquer the world
however standing between the count and
unlimited power is one five-year-old
girl as the heroes battle it out with
the monsters Dracula approaches the girl
lifts her up by the chin and angrily
demands she hand over the all-powerful
jewel the count then reveals his red
eyes and pearly whites causing the
five-year-old to scream in terror
while it worked perfectly for the scene
the young actress really was afraid it
was the first time she had seen rigor in
his full vampire regalia and the sight
of those fangs was more than enough to
make her freak out The Godfather
believe it or not some of the very best
scenes in The Godfather happened in the
spur of the moment for example remember
Vito Corleone's cat director Francis
Ford Coppola just found that feline
wandering around the studio and decided
to put it in the scene and when Vito
slaps Johnny Fontane across the face
that was Brando trying to shake up actor
Al Martino and put some life into the
scene the legendary method actor was
also doing a little improv in his final
scene moments before Vito Corleone falls
down dead he's playing with his grandson
Anthony obviously toddlers aren't
exactly natural actors since Brando
needed to connect with the kid he put an
orange peel in his mouth and began
growling like a monster but this didn't
sit well with the young actor playing
Anthony the kid was actually scared
forcing Brando to drop the game and
comfort the kid it's a nice touch to a
sad scene a unique moment of
improvisation that makes the Godfather
one of the all-time greats Close
Encounters of the Third Kind while
Richard Dreyfuss is the main character
of Close Encounters of the Third Kind
its Cary Guffey who steals the scene
every time he shows up the adorable
four-year-old played the part of Barry
Guyler the little boy who's abducted by
aliens all his reactions seem so genuine
and that's because they are throughout
shooting director Steven Spielberg was
constantly coming up with ways to
encourage Goofy's performance for
example in the scene where the boy is
smiling out the window at the UFOs
Spielberg is off screen unwrapping
presents for Guffey later on when Barry
tearfully tells his alien friends
goodbye he's really crying because
Spielberg told him to imagine his
friends leaving forever but perhaps
Spielberg's most ingenious ploy comes
earlier in the film when Barry runs into
his kitchen and spots the aliens
rummaging through his refrigerator the
space invaders are kept off camera and
the whole scene plays off Barry's face
in a matter of seconds we see the boy go
from fright to joy so what's he actually
looking at Spielberg had make up man Bob
Westmoreland dress up as a gorilla and
hide behind a cardboard partition when
Guffey ran into the room the partition
was pulled away and he was face to face
with a scary
but then the director told Westmoreland
to take off his mask
suddenly Guffey recognized the makeup
man and broke out into a big smile
Spielberg explained even though it was a
trick the reaction was pure and honest
really that's a phrase you could use to
describe almost every Spielberg film
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
there's no denying that Willy Wonka and
the Chocolate Factory is a childhood
classic but honestly it's one of the
freakiest films ever made
and that's all thanks to Gene Wilder
sure his version of Wonka is hilarious
and even occasionally soft-hearted but
there's just something off about the guy
you never know when he's going to truly
lose his mind
you lose good day sir of course
audiences weren't the only ones who
found Gene Wilder's maniacal Candy Man
frightening as it turns out the
frizzy-haired actor also terrified his
young co-stars while working on the film
director Mel Stewart like to keep all
the kids guessing hiding fee details
from them until it was actually time to
shoot a scene for example Stewart kept
the actors away from the famous
chocolate room until he was ready to
roll the camera
so when Charlie and company stepped into
Wonka's Wonderland their looks of are
genuine but then there's the infamous
boat scene widely regarded as the
scariest part of the film Stewart didn't
tell anyone what exactly was going to
happen during that boat ride
so when Wilder started going on about
hurricanes blowin in the Grizzly Reaper
mowing the kids were scared out of their
minds
actress Denise Nickerson who played
Violet Beauregarde actually thought
Wilder had gone mad really that's a
testament to Wilders acting abilities
and while he's appeared in several other
iconic films it's safe to say he'll
always be best remembered for this Kandi
Koated creep fest